the purpose of creation and ourselves in
it is for creation to become more and
more alive that is the natural tendency
of all things of the universe to become
more and more complex to become to grow
into more and more layers of complexity
to become more alive humanity has been
exploring an extreme of separation the
the the horror that it's gone down on
this planet it's super separate from the
one yes it's super cept and and and if
this planet can come back from that
place if it can go on such a deep
journey into separation into a prison
planet into more war and actually
reintegrate that is a new step of cosmic
evolution right and that's why the evil
forces are actually rendering an
efficient very service the tendency of
the universe is to become more and more
alive and our purpose in it is to
participate in the coming alive of the
universe yeah that's the that's the
basic my basic understand to participate
in the coming aliveness of the
[Music]
what's up everyone welcome to simulation
I'm your host Don Saucon so pumped to
have Charles Eisenstein joining us on
the show hi Charles
I don't thanks so much for coming on
really appreciate it super excited for
this conversation if those who don't
know Charles's background
he's a pioneering storyteller of the new
world author of several books including
the ascent of humanity sacred economics
the more beautiful world our hearts and
note is possible climate a new story and
he's the host of a new and ancient story
podcast and you can find his main link
in the bio below Charles Eisenstein
dot-org as well as his book profile page
and his Twitter all right Charles we
have to start with this question we're
both so obsessed with it where did we
come from
who are we why are we here where are we
going what is the nature of this reality
you want me to answer those questions I
mean our our culture gives us answers to
those and then we come up with our own
variants on those called on those
questions on those answers and the
answers that we are given by the culture
don't really make much sense anymore
they don't resonate with us so I've been
yeah my work is to offer different
answers or maybe even different
questions or different ways of finding
the answers or perhaps different ways of
making ourselves available for the
answers to find us and seeing more and
more the value in the question rather
than the value being in the answer the
question being an expression of the life
force underneath the question there's a
questioning or you could even say it
questing so yeah I like it I mean I'm
probably your probably not expecting me
to like answer those questions but
that's how I would begin to talk about
them I love that it's the questing as
the questioner of those questions
that is this life force awakening life
force it catalyzes such profound
awareness and consciousness shifts when
we dig into those questions and the
modalities that we can take the
different methods that we can take to
bring that question more to the essence
of our social fabric is beautiful
there's so many different ways to do so
yeah like why do you why do you even
want to ask these questions there's a
force within you that will not actually
be satisfied even when you arrive at an
answer because it's coming from it it's
coming from the desire or the imperative
to grow to become who you can be that's
the animating force that is behind the
questions so it's not actually about
finding the answers someone asked me
today the question something like um how
do i how do I reconnect how do I find a
way to belong again and I put it out
that what you're really seeking isn't
the how what you're seeking is the
actual belonging that's the drive
underneath and I think a lot of times we
take this this Drive which could even be
a frustrated life force that generates
discontent and then we displace that
onto intellectualized questions when
those are actually sometimes even an
escape from the movement that is trying
to happen within us so yeah and here you
are you know doing this this series this
podcast seeking to satisfy a deep
yearning by interviewing smart people
you have answers and hopefully inspiring
other people who watch to care more
about these questions in the way that
these questions can impact their lives
yeah I'm like you said a lot of people
also
come back to those questions and say
that it is that question that going on
that quest is the journey right not
trophy of an answer right so the
question could lead to other questions
like that might be the the ya best
effect of it anyway I'm very happy to to
be in this territory with you starting
with the questions and who knows where
it'll go I'm so interested in those
questions and a maybe a good approach to
that it with you would be maybe I just
said all that so I could avoid admitting
that I don't even know the answers if
that I I would be so surprised by people
who do and and I want to know and maybe
there could be a great civilizational
dialogue that happens around these
questions and what could potentially be
these answers let's approach this from
this idea that whether you allow
spirituality and mysticism and magic in
with your understanding of the nature of
reality or whether you take a strictly
materialistic physical scientific
approach you still go back in lineage
all of our parents and their parents and
their parents and their parents all of
our ancestors all of life on this planet
all of the stars and planets all go back
to the Big Bang what created the Big
Bang well it all goes back again to that
single source of creation and also
asking about it from that perspective of
the nature of our reality what created
this reality why was it created why are
we here will you speak about that like
allowing that little bit of you know
science is like Big Bang till now
evolution huh and then it's like what
happened before the Big Bang we don't
know yet figuring out spirituality and
mysticism and magic have like all
different ideas about what it could
intentionally be for were in a school
and we're training or spirit our
consciousness very school so yeah how
what do you
how do you interact and engage with
those okay yeah a couple things for one
you know you asked or referred to these
two different ways of answering the
question what is excuse me tutor from
two different ways of answering the
question one is the scientific path the
other is the mystical or spiritual path
I would say that I believe both of them
I am a materialist and at the same time
I think that matter is so much more
subtle and mysterious than we imagined
that when we fully comprehend or even
take one step into a deeper
comprehension of what matter is we
discover that it has the properties that
we've exported on to spirit and that
matter is not actually matter and that
ultimately science is going to take us
to the same place that other traditions
of knowledge took us to that science is
is challenging its own ideological
limits that that you you know the
program of science was to examine things
more and more carefully to quantify them
more and more extensively and to reduce
the many to the one that's the the basic
idea is to reduce the the world of
multiple of a multiplicity of phenomena
- oh that's just different permutations
of a few basic building blocks and a few
forces of nature that we can
mathematically describe the complexity
is an illusion that's all actually very
simple therefore very understandable
therefore controllable so I think that
spirituality various should some of the
traditions that you spoke of are trying
to do the same thing - to reduce a
mystery to something that we can grasp
like you mentioned oh it's just a school
or
all consciousness or it's all like to
reduce it is comforting in a way but
it's part of a paradigm of control then
infiltrates our culture on every level
and I believe that right now we face the
possibility and invitation of letting go
of that control whether we're talking
about technology or our conceptual
categories of the world or the
domestication of the wild like we've
accomplished a lot through technologies
of control mental and material but we
are reaching its limits whether you're
talking about medicine whether you're
talking about our understanding of the
world politics you know I mean back in
the day the sciences the social sciences
were supposed to work the same miracles
that the material sciences had
accomplished in the material world we
were gonna have an engineered perfect
society
thanks to political science sociology
economics and we are reaching the an
apparent limit to our to our to our
ability to improve ourselves and improve
the world and so it's calling us into a
kind of a revolution that is not just
about replacing one reductionistic
scheme with another one but to maybe
entertain the idea that reality is
irreducible that no matter how we
confine it categorize it reduce it there
will always be something left out and
that thing that is left out will be an
endless source of anomalies or you can
say miracles or or an endless source of
humiliation that something happens that
doesn't fit into your reality picture
and you're like wow I guess I didn't
know what reality really was I thought I
knew but here's something that happened
and if you have the courage to to accept
that and not toss it into the garbage
bin of anomaly or I can't explain that
or that didn't happen then you know and
you're able to take it in then an
expansion is possible or an initiation
into a larger reality than you had known
that make sense yeah yeah I want to
start with a couple points that you
listed there one of them being that this
idea that maybe it's almost say it maybe
it almost seems like then this the
reality being that I would that I
couldn't possibly and I think nothing's
impossible but that I couldn't possibly
be able to compress reality down into
some sort of exciting and
all-encompassing
storytelling experiences that could
awaken people and could just get them
super excited to be alive and bring
their unique consciousness forward into
the world and it's fine to do that it's
just that not not to imagine that you
have said everything or that your
particular offering applies universally
to all people to all times to all
situations but it could be a story that
makes people come alive and that carries
truth in it even if it is not the truth
yeah interesting so we can aim for the
absolute best as we would say here in
Silicon Valley compression algorithm of
understanding the key essences the
essentials of reality as we say with
Pareto or power law distributions that
you find the 20% of reality they
gives you an 80% understanding of what
you're actually here embedded in yeah
and then if you can tell that story to
the world then that at least gets it out
in the most compressed and excitable way
but it requires not only your parsing
for signal but it requires you to be a
really good artist and designer and
storyteller to get it out and land in
people's hearts yeah so it's not like
it's oh the metaphor of a compression
algorithm only goes so far
because imagine because the compression
algorithm that you're using is gonna
carry biases it's gonna it's gonna carry
an implicit judgement about what exists
because you're looking for certain
things looking at certain things and not
even seeing other things so imagine if
you had a image compression algorithm
that that always eliminated fairies okay
like suppose there's actually fairies
and and they if you used a different
algorithm than the image that you end up
with you'd be able to see these fairies
let me give this also as an example as
someone that is deep in philosophy it
would be like I was never born and
raised in Africa or in South America or
in Asia so I don't actually have like a
first principles first 20 years of my
life understanding of that continents
philosophies of family interactions and
life interactions in general and so
because of that I will have bias as I
make my story that's hoping to help
awaken people towards who just Who I am
and how I was born and how I was grown
up like here in the United States yeah
and so that's these ideas of these
biases okay but then this other thing
that you mentioned in that first segment
was that
this idea of letting go it's both
incredibly beautiful yet it's like if I
let go and then we you know if you let
go you wouldn't have written your books
maybe I wrote my books because I let go
because you let go okay because I let go
of what I thought I knew and that opened
up vistas that would have been veiled by
the the distorting lens that I had grown
up wearing so it's not like so what it's
not actually letting go of knowing
anything that's not what I'm talking
about it's to recognize the that the map
that you're carrying of the world is
just a map and then and that's not bad I
mean it's useful maps are useful but at
some point in in one's development the
map becomes like confining you realize
that there are things that it's not
showing and I think that that's
happening on a collective level too
there's there are features of the
terrain that are super important that
are invisible on the on the maps that we
have inherited from our modern
scientific tradition okay so our map aka
world view is limited to the stimuli
that we've taken in growing up and
experiencing as adults and from our
lineage etc and to our experiences that
we've had and so then there are certain
aspects to our existence that are really
important that are maybe not embedded in
our worldviews because we have yet to
have discovered them and the idea of is
is it of letting of letting go has
something also to do with that you just
good luck parsing for all of those
really incredibly
poor things because if you do you can do
that you can go out and parse and find
these things but also just know that
having a more you know peaceful
economist interconnected relationship
with your North Star and your journey
here is beautiful as you go and parse
and find and seek and disseminate after
you synthesize yeah you could say that
that so these maps are these worldviews
belief systems whatever you want to call
it these are not purely intellectual
they reveal the world in a certain way
that resonates or Co resonates with a
state of being of your own so as you
change and fully inhabit the particular
reality that you have constructed or
that we have constructed collectively
and grow into that and then eventually
grow up against its boundaries then the
reality starts no longer to Co resonate
with who you are becoming and that is
the time to let go there's a time not to
let go you know there's a time when when
a worldview or police system it's it's
totally working for you and your job is
to grow and to and if somebody comes and
criticizes it you're gonna be like yeah
whatever are you gonna be defensive
you're not gonna be willing or ready to
hear it and that's why I don't I'm not
out there like trying to convince people
that their map is wrong because I
respect like there's a time there's a
phase of growth there's a phase of of
limits there's a phase of crisis as a
phase of dissolution and my intention
then is to serve whatever phase whatever
is ready to happen you know and if it's
not ready to change then maybe I'll just
tell a joke you know maybe I'll just
show some love or plant a seed that
might sprout many many lifetimes in the
future
hmm okay there's also something about
this letting go that is in a sense hard
because we desire to build the new world
that our hearts know as possible we want
that world we all collect in many ways
our nodes making changes aiming to get
to that world and this so it says is
would you would you call it some sort of
ebb and flow along the way of both
building and creating and also letting
go and being interconnected and letting
go is not something that you can
actually do usually for me at least it
comes in despite becomes despite my
doing it comes when I can't do anymore
when I'm hanging on to the precipice
with all my might
terrified of falling mmm and finally my
my grip falters and I can't hold on
anymore
I like that then I don't that's a great
analogy ok so it's like you've done a
great amount of the work towards that
beautiful world you we all know our
hearts in our hearts possible and then
there's the moment of us realizing that
hey it's time for me to go play with my
kid or for me to go on that date or for
me to go and exercise or for me to go
and do these other activities that could
be part of the essence and there's also
something there that speaks to Taoism
quite a bit being on this the way but
also are we on the Dow are we on the way
have we veered completely off what are
your thoughts about that
when when you're in new territory that
how do you know what the way is except
to take wrong turns and false paths you
can only discover the true path by by
walking the false path so you could say
that there isn't no there is no false
path there is only learning from errors
and infinite opportunities to learn from
those errors including the errors that
you regret for your whole life and wish
that you hadn't done that somehow those
mistakes are recorded in the collective
field and I therefore feel grateful for
all of those who have come before me who
have made the mistakes that I no longer
need to make because their regret is
recorded in our collective consciousness
you're tapping in to learn from that
mistake and then not veering off on
everything yes everything you do is on
behalf of all beings would you call this
like a karmic lineage I would call it a
universal principle everything that you
do is on behalf of all beings this is
similar to the Bodhisattva Bodhisattva
vow which in which you declare an
intention to work for the enlightenment
of all beings but what I'm saying is
that this vow is unnecessary because
it's already happening so a more subtle
form of the vow is simply a statement of
recognition that actually I am working
on behalf of all beings that it's
already true paradoxically the statement
that it is already true the statement
the recognition of it makes it true this
is yeah getting into some some mysteries
here but so I guess I want to say this
though because one of the formulas that
has guided the modern separate self the
MOT
individual is this heroic striving this
this idea of attainment this idea that
always comes up in the question well how
do I do it that question may be based on
false premises to turn everything into
something to accomplish including your
spiritual development mmm something that
you exert your will to do hmm to find
something to overcome find something to
fight that whole that whole template the
action of non action that's just one way
to do things that hold like yeah like so
how do I do it that assumes that you are
doing it and but what if it's being done
to you that all of us embedded in this
creation are on this journey and that
journey is already on this ascension
process period yeah I mean no matter how
you state it I would probably be able to
say well that's not quite it the words
that we're using even to describe it in
introduce errors you know understanding
but they might be the right words in a
certain situation a certain relationship
truth is a relationship function so yeah
what you say might be it carries some
truth maybe to you at this moment it is
it is true not saying that there is no
such thing as truth or that it's
relative or that we make it up not
saying that but words that carry truth
in one interaction may not carry truth
in another interaction and I realize I'm
kind of dancing around here and I feel
free to try to pin me down on something
is it excellent back and forth so we
have a evolutionary trajectory embedded
within this creation that is ascending
over time
and whether we're letting go to the
process of Ascension or were actually
building the new world that our hearts
know as possible mm-hmm I it's hard for
me to envision the new world our hearts
know as possible when we're all
completely letting go but it's also hard
for me to envision the new world of our
hearts all know as possible when we're
all just builders mm-hmm but there's
yeah so there's a time for each time for
each yeah so so then what is the point
of the teleology the purpose why are we
embedded in this creation why was this
creation made why are we endeavoring
into consciousness here yeah why are we
experiencing this ascension what does it
teach us is it a teaching function what
are we the purpose of creation and
ourselves in it is for creation to
become more and more alive that is the
natural tendency of all things of the
universe to become more and more complex
to become to grow into more and more
layers of complexity to become more
alive you can see the the the organic
tendency toward life anytime you leave a
parking lot alone for 20 or 30 years if
you don't maintain that in a state of
unlife then cracks form like uniformity
becomes non-uniform and then we need to
grow up through the cracks and over time
it becomes more and more life it can
only hold it in a state of death in a
state of stasis with a lot of effort
that's so that's an example and you can
look at the history of the earth you
know becoming more and more alive more
and more complex
so human the advent of human beings on
earth is introducing the possibility of
a next level of complexity ssin where
where we have ways of exchanging
information that are new and therefore
new levels of life so the multicellular
body is is one level of life and then a
society civilization that's a new level
and this is just the beginning
where we are going is totally
inconceivable but that is our that's why
we're here that's why we're created is
to participate in the coming of life of
the cosmos and that's why as an
individual if you are evaluating your
life and trying to make a choice the
thing that makes you feel alive is the
thing that is participating in life that
is serving life you might be bribed or
frightened coerced into spending your
life energy on something that does not
serve life but you're not gonna feel
fully alive doing it you're not gonna
feel like you're living your life you'll
feel like you're living the life
someone's paying you to live mmm-hmm and
there will be an unmet longing that
constantly seeks satisfaction yes and
then this is what generates the economy
the the manufacturing of of artificial
needs you know it's an addiction if the
one thing that you're really seeking is
unavailable which is to fully express
your gifts and service to life well
instead here you know have a sports car
if you are missing the deep security of
belonging of being part of of the
process of creation
because that's really what makes us feel
at home it's to belong in participation
in the process of creation if you're
missing that then you're gonna feel
insecure mm-hmm you're gonna feel not at
home oh maybe some financial security
some investments and I could go through
many many addictions that all illustrate
the same principle Wow all right let's
stay on this for a little bit so we have
the purpose of creation is two words you
used used alive and complexity mm-hmm
okay life is the name that we give to a
certain unfolding of complexity of
complexity okay life is we get us giving
the name to the unfolding of complexity
and then when we don't feel belonging to
life and complexity then the propensity
for us to fall away from beautiful
bringing forth of our gifts into the
world we succumb to that one more one
more thought on that page is this idea
of the Ouroboros theory of source that
rather than thinking linearly from
simplicity to complexity that we think
cyclically that once we have the initial
source code that made us the made
creation that we then embed that in our
complexity and start the next cycle of
creation of life evolving to complexity
again and that therefore we are embedded
right in it and that this function this
objective function as you list is life
and complexity
and then more life more alive creation
feeling more alive yeah more conscious
experience more finding meaning we're
finding expressing creativity would
those be good words would you say
meaning consciousness creativity gifts
gems uh-huh yeah I could play with any
of those words
the discovery and/or construction of
meaning is part of the the search for
meaning let's say is part of the
expression of it's just like the
question that I mentioned at the
beginning like what is the quest what is
a quest the quest is a journey with a
sacred purpose so ultimately pilgrimage
is another pilgrimage is the female
counterpart of a quest mm-hmm a quest is
a masculine journey a pilgrimage is a
feminine journey and both of them are
necessary the pilgrimage does not know
its object mmm pilgrimage is is a state
of openness it's a journey that that
you're in which you're open to receive
something from beyond your knowing and
quest knows a quest is very
goal-oriented okay yeah pilgrimage is
open nan yeah that's the way I'm I'm
engaging it anyway I mean you know these
words can be used in whatever you
whatever way you like but yeah yeah
pilgrim is you're not actually properly
you're not trying to accomplish anything
that you know you're opening yourself to
be accomplished by something by a place
something's gonna happen to you anyway
yeah so what is the quest what is the
sacred purpose what is the driver of our
questions why do you want to know the
answers to these to these metaphysical
questions like what where's this
curiosity coming from mm-hmm and I would
say that it is an expression of the the
of your deep imperative to participate
more fully in the coming a lot of the
universe that's a great that's what
drives it so the feeling of many of us
here caring more for these questions the
feeling is
channeled by creation itself wanting to
feel more alive and belonging in the
path of Ascension yeah I mean I don't
usually think of it in terms of
ascension why do you not think of it in
terms of ascension well I mean this goes
back thousands of years to the advent of
civilization in which there were that
with the advent of social classes at the
bottom was the farmer and and at the top
was the king and the priests and in the
middle were artisans and soldiers and
things like that so if you wanted to
raise your status I mean even like that
word why why is high good and low bad
well this has an origin in that time
when when the the low the the inferior I
mean all of these are using the same
value system that high is good and low
is bad that originated because farmers
were worthy they were close to the soil
and progress meant you know progress in
your status in society excuse me meant
ascending the social hierarchy until you
were the king and your feet were not
even allowed to touch the ground in a
lot of ancient societies the Kings feet
were not allowed to touch the ground
the priests temple was separate from the
earth and from the soil so this became
encoded in a paradigm of progress that
says that our destiny is to rise above
nature to be no longer dependent on
nature to be spiritual to be
intellectual to be rational therefore
the most prestigious of the sciences is
theoretical physics the most abstract or
maybe mathematics you know that's the
most abstract much more prestigious than
applied physics which is more
prestigious than engineering which is
more prestigious than plumbing which is
more prestigious than
pharming so that's that's the order so
this whole idea of Ascension of leaving
matter behind of abstracting ourselves
from going of going off into space of
entering the pristine world of the mind
or the pristine world of the Spirit
where you are not dirty why is dirty bad
why did we associate spirituality with
cleanliness why do they wear white robes
why do we speak of high vibrations this
all encodes a value system that's rooted
in the original hierarchical structures
of the first mass civilizations but on
on the other hand we know like that like
that that is changing now a lot of
people want to go back to the land to
want to have their hands in the soil
they want to they don't use usually the
term but I would like to lower my
vibration I would like to reincorporate
some of these suppressed
low vibrations to be more earthy is a
bath soon worse than a flute you know
why is higher better than lower why does
superior mean better this is you can see
from this the the depth of the undoing
that is upon us or the depth of the
revolution that is upon us to overturn
that fundamental a paradigm to embrace
our fullness as material beings and not
seek to escape into spirituality a
materiality to afraid that not to it
seek to escape a materiality that has
been made almost uninhabitable because
of the very effort to escape materiality
the denial of the sacredness of the
material makes the material into
something profane makes it into
commodities makes it into parking lots
and strip mines and ugly very efficient
but ugly
constructed world that has been stripped
of its qualities leaving only its
quantities that is not a fit habitation
for the human soul so of course we seek
to escape into some spiritual world but
that's because we've rendered the
material world profane the revolution
that we are in that you are part of is
to take a different course to stop doing
that to bring the material and the
spiritual back together to reinvest the
world with sacredness to unify mind and
body to unify heart and end mind that's
what is upon us today or that's the
opportunity that we have and nothing
less will enable us to fully participate
in the creative process of the universe
okay so then that is one of the core
principles if not the core principle of
aliveness of creation is the bringing
together of the heart and the mind and
you gave us these examples throughout
the hierarchy is such a very serious
conversational topic and it's very
interesting and hearing from you about
people being at the low farming people
being at the high that could never touch
the ground on being as close to the gods
as possible very interesting but also
that the idea of a hierarchy of decision
goes all the way back to the initial
bits of life that exists its period life
had to decide even at the single-cell
organism level when to go and find food
when it was ready to divide these had to
happen these decisions had to happen
just like even today with us we have
stomach empty food priority you know
these are just embedded but it's there
then how do you then is is there some
sort of like header are kacal approach
that comes with you know you
I don't think hierarchies bad I'm not
anti hierarchy okay yeah soon and I'm
not anti structure how does a hierarchy
work with this and again you didn't use
this process of or you can use this word
of essentially you actually kind of
described in a way why you weren't using
the word ascension because we are kind
of we're fishing back down to find these
roots of our interconnectedness with
nature and boomerang that back up to
where we hope to continue evolving
mmm-hmm is that kind of a yeah that's
incorporating some missing pieces some
neglected pieces that are invisible from
within our operating Maps you know we
can return to that metaphor as well
things that are barely even recognized
to exist or are relegated to the margins
or devalued in our economic system for
example anything that is not easily
convertible into money tends to get
devalued gets even love intimacy family
it's not that we say that those are not
important but what do you have less and
less time for the more you are immersed
in a money economy what gets
functionally pushed to the edges the way
that I recently unpacked it myself was I
think the first thing that goes to sleep
mmm-hmm which we do spend a third of our
lives doing it is so crucial to our
wellness I'm so crucial okay okay then
the next thing that goes like you were I
think just listing love family time
right your kids and your friends and
because why because I need to climb up
the hierarchy I need to make more money
I need to well could you speed economic
desperation you know it's not
necessarily that that you're possessed
by a delusion I mean a lot of I think
the
median income in the United States is
like it's under $40,000 you know people
are are working you know two or three
jobs so it's not that you know people
adopt these distorted values it's that
that the system enforces these values
whether we embrace them or not
so systemically yeah what gets pushed
out to the outskirts to the margins what
gets sacrificed it's the things that are
not measurable if something's not
measurable if it's a qualitative
property of life then it's really hard
to subject it to it the market to
incorporate it into economic growth and
so we see we have a society that is
getting richer and richer and everything
that we can measure like we have twice
the floorspace per capita as we did in
the 1950s or 1960s we have but
well-being right right these yet this is
what gets sacrificed the things we can't
measure like community yeah like you can
kind of quantify leisure but it really
the essence of leisure escapes
quantification you can measure time but
you can't measure how you feel in that
time do you feel like you are on your
own timeline that there's nothing
hanging over your head
mm-hmm so people might have actually I
think even measurable leisure peaked in
the 1970s in the United States I read
that somewhere I'll know if it's true of
it but yeah because that is around the
same time that median male income became
stagnating compared to the GDP which is
continuing to increase yeah in other
words where are those fruits going
apparently fifty percent of all new
income that's generated goes to the one
percent uh-huh which is
mind blowing hmm and uh well well then
the question is what well how well first
is how did they do that
what what were they were they were they
providing extremely great value to
society
were they reshaping rules and
regulations in just their own favor and
could it potentially be that people that
are of such a high amount of money
making have the greatest amount of
potential to increase the amount of
aliveness that this creation roars with
but this is a very tough thing to dive
into and understand yeah yeah I mean we
could talk about that you know my point
was more of the the systemically
enforced values of the quantifiable the
economic machinery in a sense that's
right yeah I like born as a child and
you become embedded in the economic
machinery there's like no exit door left
right on the economic machinery and the
non-economic parts of life have receded
over certainly over my lifetime there
used to be a lot more of life that was
not in the money realm yeah you know
like if you needed to fix your roof you
might not even hire roofers like some
neighbors might get together and help
you that maybe was more in my father's
generation than in my generation but
there was still some of that left child
care was often not a paid service you
know neighbors would watch the kids and
so forth
cooking was not a paid service mom
cooked
you didn't supermarkets didn't have
delis or they didn't have like prepared
food people didn't eat in restaurants as
much advice companionship
you know you didn't go to a life coach
or counselor as much as you do today so
many functions have entered the money
realm that were not in it before because
it's so crucial to increase the GDP well
it's aesthetically necessary to increase
the GDP yeah there's like a these are
activities no worries let's add throw
them in that Kanak motion right but what
I'm saying is that it's not just you
know some Dogma that gee you know GDP
represents well-being like that there is
that Dogma but the growth of GDP
economic growth is systemic Lee
necessary in a system where money is
created as interest-bearing debt that's
what I wrote a whole book about that and
it's a it's a mistake it's an inaccuracy
let's say to blame all that's happening
on the greed of wealthy people or the
nefarious plots of the power elite or
something like that all of that is a
symptom greed is a symptom the the
neoliberal austerity programs are a
symptom of a deeper imperative of the
system and that imperative of growth is
embedded in the mythology the defining
stories of civilization which is in in
those stories growth is is is our
destiny the expansion of the human realm
this has been what civilization has been
about the conquest of nature for
thousands of years and even in science -
its - the ambition of science is to
bring more and more of the world into
the realm of the quantitative something
in science is only real if you can
measure it if you can describe it with
numbers to treat something
scientifically you have to make data out
of it like how would you like what would
be a scientific treatment of emotions
you'd have to
describe them in terms of you know girl
patterns and peptides and
neurotransmitters and you know something
that you could measure then it's a
science so science mirrors economics in
that we have an expansion of the
quantified realm and a shrinking of that
which cannot be measured or quantified
so that's part of the stripping of
sacredness from matter that's really
abstract I hope I didn't go too far
that's beautiful though yeah okay so as
we grow which we're on trajectory to
continue growing and becoming more alive
that again this boomerang function of
going and grabbing that initial
interconnectedness of all things the
nature the beauty those things and
embedding them in our future so this
seems like okay we're in creation
creation is about increasing aliveness
and complexity in order for us to best
do that where we are today is to look
back at some of the things from our past
as a deep again aliveness of
interconnectedness of unity of nature of
these types of things and embed them in
as we go forward so in a sense I was
mentioning this to you before we started
it really feels like things are moving
in the direction of making super
intelligence everyone and their mother
is talking about AI everyone's now
talking about quantum supremacy people
are talking about indistinguishable
virtual realities neuro tech biotech
everything is up and up and up and up in
a better yet the most popular things
that people are watching on video in
China in the United States are many
times these primitive technology YouTube
channels and on their Chinese correlate
platforms that people are literally
watching how we used to hunt and gather
and build with our hands in nature and
embedded
trees while we program superintelligence
how does that function sit with you okay
alright so first I'll say that I'm not
you know opposed to AI or opposed I
don't think that this is all a big
mistake but I think that we have to
recognize the what the appropriate
application of the technologies of
quantity is what is the appropriate
application of the technologies of
quantity they can accomplish certain
things but the most is a mistake to
think that everything can be brought
into that realm so yeah so like take AI
if you can describe a problem
numerically like if you can define a
define a desired outcome in terms of
some data like say chess you know like
there's there's no ambiguity about what
victory is in chess you can describe
that algorithmically and you can then
create a self self-adjusting artificial
intelligence program that can play chess
better than a human being can
competitive self play is the big key
right yeah right I mean and those can
even outperform brute force chess
engines so like Mila and um alpha zero
right the more general question of can a
I outperform human intelligence in every
way depends on an assumption that all
expressions of human intelligence are in
at bottom quantitative that everything
that a human being is and does is
somehow reducible to a data set mm-hmm
that and it's the same ideology
that is at the basis of science that
says everything that is real is
measurable this goes back to Galileo the
ambition of science is to encompass
everything in number that to assume that
is possible is to make up is to make a
statement about that's that is a
metaphysical statement it is a doctrine
about reality
only the measurable is real and that
everything is measurable everything can
be reduced to quantity maybe it's true
but we have to recognize that that is an
assumption and what I have observed is
that like if you look at AI generated
art or something like that there's
always something missing in it there's
at least what I've seen for now right so
is that always going to be the case is
there something in beauty that escapes
quantity that is beyond quantity is
there is there something else if there
isn't then yeah there's no reason why I
can't become more human than human
beings are because human beings aren't
actually human we're just a we two are
reducible to a bunch of space-time
coordinates operated on by mathematical
forces that has been the reigning
ideology for a couple hundred years most
human beings who have lived on earth did
not think that they didn't think that
nature was in essence predictable and
controllable mm-hmm and I think that we
are discovering that it as well that it
is not that there are well
I could go in different directions with
that but oh maybe I'll just pause right
now
okay yeah all right there's within me
this urge to understand from you from
your perspective that it seems to be
more and more that there is this desire
for owning nature owning other humans
owning the planet owning the next
celestial bodies that we go to owning
the substrate that everybody goes into
to play in these virtual worlds it's all
about who owns it mm-hmm all about that
yeah what forces are at play in creation
that are not tangible invisible here in
this physical world
I'm trying to decide whether to comment
on the expansion of the realm of the
owned or yours
where you got to from that I'm trying to
see the link it seems as though that
expansion of the world of the owned is
there are there are forces channeling
through okay yeah the the desire to
expand the realm of the owned or let's
take it on a personal level the desire
to own more and more to is is the desire
to expand the separate self and to exert
to it's it's a desire to dominate if you
own something then you decide what
happens to it you get to this is the
ancient Roman concept of ownership you
can can remember the Roman the Latin but
it was you know you can use it or abuse
it you can do what anything anything you
want with it it's yours it's as if it
becomes part of you so what is the
origin of this desire to expand the self
I think it is because of the stripping
of the full complement of relationships
that are the the true self the true self
is not a separate individual the true
self is not a skin encapsulated ego it's
not a bubble of psychology inside of
flesh robot the that that is a truncated
version of the self the true self is a
is is a nexus of relationships that
include everything it is a holographic
mirror of all that is so or more
practically speaking like historically
or pre historically to exist meant if
you if you were alive then you were in
deep intimate relationship with every
person
and every pull every feature of the
landscape every bird every tree every
plant everything you knew them really
well and they knew you really know you
you you knew the story of every person
that you saw and you knew their
grandfather's story there was no
pretending actually because you were so
deeply known that is what it's like to
be at home in the world so in an
industrial society most of those
relationships are stripped from us we
and so and we were cast into a sea of
strangers other people and the trees
like how many people in the United
States could identify more than ten
different trees mm-hmm much less know
when each tree flowers but ten different
brands no problem right right and so so
the the atrophy of our full relatedness
leaves us profoundly insecure the the
infinite connected self has been
cordoned off into this cramped lonely
separate self and so what does that
separate self want it wants to recover
its lost beingness one way to recover
that lost beingness is to seek to expand
itself by getting more money more
property more control more domination
this will never achieve its desire
because the desire is for an infinite
web of relations so how much of the
finite does it take to compensate for
the loss of the infinite mm-hm
how much of the profane does it take to
compensate for the loss of the sacred
how much pornography does it take to
compensate for the loss of intimacy how
much social status does it take to
compensate for the loss of respect
an infinite amount is what it takes so
that generates greed and the desire to
expand the realm of the owned so
everybody's burdened with that with that
hunger everybody is is experiencing that
poverty so of course we generate a
society where everybody's trying to get
more and more and more and what do you
think is at play going on through people
who are the players in creation that are
coming through humans on this big board
game of risk monopoly Sims yeah I mean
you could look at it in terms of
archetypal forces playing themselves out
evil forces but ultimately they too are
in service of creation they too are in
service of the world coming more of the
universe even coming more and more alive
the journey of separation has brought
with it tremendous development ok so we
have the creations objective function of
becoming more alive and then we have the
the even entities or other forces that
are at play that are in service to
aliveness that are archetypal forces
that are then aptly through us to make
this an interesting process of becoming
more alive yeah those forces those
beings may not know that they are in
service to the universe becoming more
alive but they are part of this
inconceivably mysterious orchestration
everything is born into the universe for
for a reason and it's always the same
reason ultimately ok and then what would
you say these forces are
they are beings
what are these beings there's many many
kinds of these beings and different
cultures have different names for them
yeah I don't have my favorite typology
there's many ways to look at it yeah I
mean we could go into you know I mean
there's whole it seems like taxonomy zuv
you know extraterrestrials or yeah non
material beings sure yeah I haven't you
know I have I have some of these taxon
on these on my radar screen but I
haven't elaborated on them in detail you
have to ask somebody else about that and
and different people will have different
answers we've had a couple people on the
show that talked about you're right
there's different answers to tax and tax
the taxonomy of the classification of
forces or entities that are at play
through us on the planet is fascinating
and then we also very frequently talk
about the interplay between them in this
what seems like both a beautiful
aliveness that's coming but also this
predation farm a predation farm and
aliveness that are yeah going up at the
same so so yeah and the line is becoming
so much more thin that it's becoming
more transparent you can tell who is
awake and who is not more and more
easily through the transparency that is
coming with the internet and exponential
technology okay so let me let me say
that Kay that like okay so let's step
into the world of nefarious evil forces
the negative alien agenda
okay all that kind of stuff I assume
that you're a little bit or maybe a lot
familiar with it yeah these beings are
only able to operate in an Co resonance
with a human state of being we're not
there helpless victims but our personal
and collective evolutionary stage
necessitates these archetypal forces to
be at play with us they are part of the
full exploration of the particular
corner of the realm of separation that
then civilization is exploring right now
the more interconnected that we become
the more we feel belonging the more we
feel that unity that then it's both the
less we feel this need to dominate and
control and the less that then these
these negative forces can come in and
take root in our free will yeah that's
yes that's true and humanity has been
exploring an extreme of separation the
the the horror that has gone down on
this planet is almost unknown in the
galaxy it's it's this it's super
separate from the one yes it's super SEP
and and and if this planet can come back
from that place if it can go on such a
deep journey into separation yeah into
prison planet into war and actually
reintegrate that is a new step of cosmic
evolution that whatever happened before
that would have been a pretty big
boomerang throw into the
craziness of the economic machinery and
predation form all this type of stuff
dope dopamine monkeys all this type of
stuff that's a depression anxiety yeah
pump me up right yeah and throw it all
the way over there and then go be able
to evolve through that towards the one
towards the interconnectedness of with
rentier and with each other belonging
its aliveness that's a new step it's the
same principle as as as like if you run
into somebody who had like the most
horrific childhood you can imagine you
know tied to the bed by his father and
beaten with a baseball bat and locked in
a closet and made to eat his own [ __ ]
and like I mean you hear these stories
sometimes and then you meet them and a
lot of you know end up doing the same to
the next generation but some of them you
know become these radiant beings because
of what they've healed from Wow and you
recognize that they have done that
healing on behalf of all beings to
return to that theme that's us on the
micro level of an evil that's what this
planet that's the service that this
planet is rendering it doesn't guarantee
that we're gonna make it through we
could end up with a dead earth we could
destroy everything but the so there's no
guarantees right just as there's no
guarantee that the horribly abused child
is going to grow up to be a radiant
mm-hmm angel carrying love but it can
happen and when it does happen that is a
medicine for the whole planet we're
getting through our traumas but in order
for us to really express our treasures
galactically universally it's gonna
require a lot of sense yourself work to
identify this traumas heal but that that
is how radiant a being earth can become
if we can heal from this trauma that
we've gone through every time somebody
like that's what I say to people when I
when I when I run into people who have
really suffered horribly I say like if
you accomplish nothing else in your life
but to heal and not pass that on you
actually demonstrating a principle of
healing to the whole planet if it could
happen to you it can happen to everybody
it can happen to the planet you're
shifting reality into alignment with
your own healing by healing and the same
yeah on a planetary collective level the
same principle operates so all of these
negative forces all these dark forces
they are actually rendering an
evolutionary service to the galaxy or to
the cosmos by creating the conditions
for this healing to even have have to
happen yeah yeah and this resonates with
certain Gnostic teachings that say that
the that the world is in the hands of a
usurper that that there's a false god
that is actively making hell on earth
how is that a service well being cast
into this hell it calls little sound to
hell and then our our flowers and our
leaves reach the heavens afterward yeah
and and the capacities that we develop
when love is hard mmm when we have an
intense gradient to go against like we
would never discover how powerful we are
as lovers and as healers if we weren't
in these adverse conditions if we were
just gifted a utopic love scenario right
right and that's why the evil forces are
actually rendering an evolutionary
service this is super esoteric I love
this Oh like I'm like are these like
Silicon Valley like gearheads listening
to this where they think yeah you're
great
no the audience is worldwide and the
audience is in just I love gearheads by
the way it wasn't an insult but yeah
embedded with people that care about
science spirituality just overall this
alive in this process that's coming so
we often talk about this stuff like you
know I'm that's what you about are gonna
change that's our job our job is to get
these profound wisdoms that don't
normally come up
to shine on the show so that other
people can just be like whoa how do I
take that and run with it and because
you're highlighting the importance of
healing there was so beautiful well that
we had did we go through this process of
that that creation has the negative
entities that have the hold on this on
this predation farm at times that then
creates the incredible amount of love
that there's no guarantees that we get
through the little tiny pinhole that we
have to get through in order to make
sure that we that we continue the
process of aliveness but when we do we
will have lit learned and loved at
unprecedented capacities that then we
embed in where we go I think that's very
beautiful and there's a bigger mission
here to okay even if this planet doesn't
make it still every contribution we make
toward this passage still registers in
effect so this is hard to understand
from the perspective of linear time but
no action is wasted every experience
moment moment that you have in your
adventure of consciousness goes to
creation go right a source right and
whether the entire planet ceases to
exist in a couple hundred years yeah not
and besides there's not actually one
future how many are there there are many
future timelines that are converging on
the present and they you know they're in
a quantum superposition so which one is
the real future this is actually through
the past two there's not just one past
so there's an infinite amount of earths
orbiting stars that have Charles and
Alan talking well you could say that but
then you run into the problem what is is
mean because is as we use it in code
it's a Cartesian reality where something
either is or it isn't but can so you get
a superposition yeah okay but but you
could just say that there are many
futures and which one becomes real is
the one that we come into relationship
with with that we align to yeah and that
all the futures exist and then we
collapse the probability towards the one
that we right make a relationship with
right yeah yeah so which one do we want
to so every afterwards every act of love
is a kind of a a quantum measurement hmm
that puts us in relationship to a world
of love that's another way of that's a
good explaining morphic resonance you
know you you are shape-shifting the
world into alignment with every choice
that you make which means that every
person is equally powerful on this earth
and every choice is equally impactful
although one person that engages with a
million people in their in the
organization that they run or in the
social sphere that they can send a
message out to they could potentially
create a bigger splash of love they can
make a bigger wave on the surface and on
a short timescale it may look as if
they've had a bigger effect than the
single mom taking care of an autistic
child that never goes viral that no one
ever finds out about our celebrates yeah
but on but those people are altering the
deep currents that might surface only in
500 or 5,000 years yeah but no less
important than anything you're doing
with your big platform that's an
important realization to have because
then you'll no longer value the big over
the small you won't necessarily devalue
the big maybe your calling is to do
something you know on this level but you
won't think that you're more important
than anybody
that's also very interesting thing to
quantify / feel that it becomes part of
your ethos when someone sits with
millions of people that they can
disseminate content to versus someone
that's like you said raising a child
that is having troubled experiences with
the natural world that may be like the
care that goes into raising that child
maybe because of that that child turns
into a wonderful parent himself sure and
maybe that gets passed down and passed
down and passed down and maybe in five
hundred years that's the person who is
you know the global sure doing
incredible work just because of that
just because of that thing Bob five
child yeah yeah we don't know how this
world okay that's that's beautifully
said you go a couple generations into
the future and you can see incredible
effects of that yet that butterfly
effect take off okay I want to ask you
about solutions there are a lot of
things that are being propagated as
solutions to our boomeranging going
towards that interconnectedness and
bringing that up as we build the super
intelligence and as we bring more
aliveness to the world one of the things
that's really powerful is of course the
use of meditation the use of
psychedelics the use of these inward
experiences but also bringing it outward
bringing it out into the world bringing
that love forth and those increments
another one that's literally a part of
our social contract is inclusive stake
holding so moving away from self dealing
which happened which did not happen as
much back in the day where you had me
telling you a story for our inclusive
fitness versus now telling you a story
for self dealing so this idea of
inclusive fitness inclusive stake
holding is that I gate I give the
opportunity to through token aa mcc's
through a bunch of different
methodologies to
everyone in as a stakeholder of the
future and so it's not just the classic
example of the drivers of the cars and
the people riding in the cars as getting
nothing but getting tokens of ownership
the community that the company is in
gets tokens of ownership the physician
and the patient have an inclusive stake
holding relationship the teacher in the
student how do you like that as a
solution well I think it would be easy
to critique those things but I think
that they are they are a kind of a
groping toward the recovery of the
principle of gift into economics they
are yeah they're they're coming from an
understanding that that where we want to
go is is a world that that expresses and
embodies the principle that we're all in
this together that your well-being is to
my benefit - yes which is different from
the classic laissez-faire economy where
we're all in competition with each other
and if you gain the means to repay your
debts then that deprives me of that
money in the scarcity based system we're
in competition for each other if you get
the job I don't and so forth like that
is contrary to nature I mean there is
competition in nature but fundamentally
ecology is a circle of gift mmm if one
species is removed extinguished
everybody suffers the whole system gets
less resilient every species is as I
said earlier born into being to
contribute to the aliveness of the whole
mm-hmm and the same thing is true in a
social ecology in a mature meta organism
that humanity wants to become so these
these systems that you're talking about
are kind of reaching for an economy in
which more for you is more for me just
as it was in an ancient gift economy
where if you were very successful if you
were very
excellent if you were a great hunter if
you were really clever then everybody
would benefit from that because you
didn't keep and hoard for yourself
wealth was not an individual function
the best place to store extra food is in
your friends stomach right yeah that was
a quote from an indigenous person that I
mentioned in my book I store my meat in
the belly of my brother because like
this guy was like the anthropologists
said why don't you store your meat why
don't you smoke it why don't you keep it
you know you get a big you kill a big
game and you have a feast and you give
it away to everybody and the next day
you have none left and you could have
security for a month why did you do that
and he was like yeah you don't
understand I I do store meat it's in the
belly of my brother he's generous and
then everybody's gonna invite him to his
feast to that's how an economy could
work where you celebrate the success of
somebody else because now they're gonna
have more to share compersion I feel joy
when you feel joy yeah right so that's a
spiritual principle it's a movement of
consciousness but it has not yet
manifested in our economic systems in
our organizations so we're striving for
that and trying out all these
experiments so in their actual mechanics
you know I might be able to critique
tokenization or you know all of these
social currencies and things like that I
mean there's definitely things to
critique about them but the underlying
impulse I believe is a transition to
gift economy yeah yeah
so then how about strategies for
non-separation experiences of
non-separation
[Music]
yeah for me these experiences come as a
gift they're not something that I can
that I from a place of separation can
engineer but I can create an invitation
for those experiences to find me the
search generates the discovery it's like
in the matrix if you remember neo is on
his computer typing in what is the
matrix he's searching but no matter
where his what he's searching everything
his entire search is happening inside
the matrix but his search the sincerity
and commitment of his search makes him
visible to Morpheus so that Morpheus is
able to find him because of the
diligence of his search and then in
their first interview he says I've been
looking for you for a long time so I
think that our our sincerity and our
hopeless efforts to transcend the matrix
that we are trapped in is what makes us
findable by those beings that are
wanting to liberate us from the matrix
and those so those experiences of
non-separation
there they are the instruments of that
liberation we incrementally bring in
that with our will into the potential
futures that exists and then we are then
brought that gift
we're met with that gift of finding more
modalities of non separation yeah
experiences of it right so all of these
modalities none of them are a guarantee
you know you could meditate for 20 years
and not have a transcendent experience
as someone that's obsessed with creation
design so literally being creation and
designing the world that makes aliveness
more more aliveness how would you design
creation I would start by recognizing
that any creation worth living in would
be far beyond my capacity to design it
and to see myself therefore as a
participant in a design that is
unfolding that is well beyond my
understanding that I might be able to
contribute to and then it becomes a
matter of listening for or washing for
the next unfolding of that design that
calls me into participation and and to
learn to recognize what is mine to do
what is my role to play what is my gift
to give how can I make myself available
as one of the instruments of a designer
beyond my knowing my puny attempts to
design something such as in the sacred
economics book like I recognize those
probably probably everything I'm saying
is wrong in those probably if if these
were actually implemented they would
fail miserably but their failure would
would be a stepping stone toward a next
failure and a next failure in the next
failure which ultimately would add up to
a what you might call a success more and
more closer to the pinnacle of what
we're aiming to achieve yeah well these
failures are part of the design process
yeah of a greater design part of the
creation process yeah I'm obsessed with
that designer question and it's
interesting hearing people's yeah I mean
this idea that that see this is part of
an ideology that holds the the universe
outside of ourselves as without
intelligence
and then irrigates to human beings the
sacred duty of imposing intelligence
onto a world that has none imposing
order on to a world that has none
it's the ideology that says that the
natural tendency of the universe is
towards disorder toward entropy toward
thermodynamic dissolution and that is
really an obsolete scientific view the
tendency of the universe as I keep
saying is toward complexity if that's
the case if there is an intelligence not
outside the universe guiding it not
outside materiality but inherent in
materiality if there is a organic
constitutional movement toward order
toward complexity then we no longer have
to be the impose errs of order we no
longer have to be the designers so we
can design with the source code to go
towards complexity yeah we can
participate in the unfolding of
complexity we're not we're not like in
the central driver's seat nor will we
ever be why will we not be if our we can
try but we will recognize how limited we
are as we do so and the process of
recognizing our limitations the
humiliation of crashing into our
limitations we thought we knew we
thought we knew how to do this we
thought we we could design a perfect
society or a perfect world and look what
happened that learning process is part
of a larger transhuman design process
like to set us up to fail but it creates
movement it's part of the it's part of
these feedback loops these these
nonlinear feedback loops that are so
much bigger than humanity so I'm not
saying don't try
but if you can recognize that that
everything that we work with in our
design toolkit is based on such a
limited map yes then maybe that
recognition will allow us to learn more
quickly from our mistakes to not hold on
to something that's not working we gain
more and more insight about the totality
of the map of creation as we probe it
more and more right and then we if
possible to gain all insight about the
source code the underlying source code
from the initial source until today
roaring complexity that exists and then
to be able to create another cycle of
that ourselves or quadrillions of cycles
of yet the source code is is infinite
because then how else does it create
more aliveness wrap but through yeah but
through us making more hmm that's part
of the process yeah
what other things make more aliveness
besides us making more creations making
more cycles well there are many many
beings in the universe that are part of
the unfolding of aliveness what other
beings elemental beings solar beings
what are the terrestrial beings what are
those what are elemental and solar
beings
they really
they are patterns of information and
energy they are you know self-sustaining
sometimes replicating patterns of
information and energy that are
sometimes vastly more complex than a
human being is or just very different
than human being is I'm not an expert on
these beings I just know that they exist
okay
there are beings like this is like I
don't know this might disqualify me from
any serious conversation but I believe
that there are beings inside the Sun
that are alive the Sun is way more
complex than people think it's not just
this this nonlinear fusion uniform fall
of fusing hydrogen gas like the the
electromagnetic structures in the Sun
are enduring and and incredibly complex
there's no rational reason to think that
the Sun is not alive and most human
beings who have ever been on earth
recognized that the Sun is alive
most human beings on earth think it's
the God not necessarily yeah a lot of
people did think it's gay God it is in
many ways the thing that gave us life
yes well yeah so it's definitely part
but most people lived in a world full of
beings it's surrounded by beings
everything is a being okay so
potentially the birth of a star is the
birth of life or the birth of elements
is a birth of life you might be
reincarnated as a star
imagine that you might be reincarnated
as a planet you might be reincarnated as
a rock it's interesting thinking how
that feels so that's that's my favorite
stuff is what is the conscious
experience of a star or planet etc or a
rock or a rock yeah there are they just
gets like rained on by water their their
rocks are very quiet so how connected
would you be to all that is all the time
sure on the note of quadrillions of
simulations and us playing God do you
feel like this is a simile
if this is a simulation then what is a
simulation yes like we have an idea of
what a simulation is but to say that
reality's a simulation
already changes what the word simulation
means this is this is this is a very old
philosophical riddle the brains and bats
proposition you know what if what if
this isn't real what if this is just
we're all brains and bats like in the
matrix and we're just you know given the
simulation of reality which is just a
stimulation of neurons in these brains
and bats well what we mean by real is
nothing other than these simulations so
I think it's a meaningless proposition
but but where it's going to is basically
to recognize that there are that the
reality that we're familiar with is is a
tiny corner of what is really there
mm-hmm
is is humanity a biological bootloader
for digital super intelligence
that is maybe only there might be part
of what we are digital super
intelligence is an unfolding of
complexity but as I said before its
domain is very limited from a
quantitative mindset it seems like it's
domain is is huge and that we could do
anything with it it could accomplish
anything but its accomplishments are
limited to the tiny corner of the
universe that is the that is the realm
of quantity the things that can be
achieved through the manipulation of
data and number are they look huge from
where we are in a society that is
dominated by quantity all that stuff I
talked about before bye-bye efficiency
by the maximization of some measurable
thing that's what efficiency means by
money right another form of measure so
it seems like we're like the Frog at the
bottom of the well and it looks like and
the well is the well of the quantitative
and therefore the in principle
controllable it's it's it's this narrow
realm that we have declared ourselves
the Lords of but it is very very narrow
it's a tiny piece of reality and there
are there have been and still are
cultures on this planet that are living
in a much vaster realm and able to
accomplish things that are totally
beyond anything we or any of our AI
could ever accomplish what are those
things
so for example
a
I was a bit of a leap but I am spoke to
some Dogon about climate change ask them
what do you guys think about climate
change and they said oh yeah
the climate is really spinning out of
control and the reason is that you've
been taking sacred artifacts that have
been buried ceremonially were placed
ceremonially and keep our places on the
earth and you've been taking them away
and putting them in museums in New York
and London thereby disrupting the
Covenant that has been maintained
between humans and the planet that that
allows a planet to maintain a habitation
for Humanity and you're you're
disrupting that so this is a technology
that is completely off the radar screen
a technology the technology of ceremony
the technology of Earth's powerpoints
you cannot find those through any
Geological Survey the entire dataset of
all of the world's computers does not
contain the information that is
necessary to exercise that technology if
I ran the simulations and then I moved
those artifacts in one and then watch
the evolution of humanity and then I
left them in the other and watch the
evolution of humanity we could see what
the results are of things like that that
are deemed to be so sacred that even
super intelligence can figure it out
yeah but you can't you can only run that
experiment once you can run it
quadrillions of times in different
permutations that's the beauty of super
intelligence well you couldn't go back
in time and move those artifacts and
repeat the experiment you only live once
well I would launch that many from the
beginning and then be able to observe
their evolution and then launch another
quadrillion if I'd like because we have
the godlike superpowers of the source
your ability is to simulate it depends
on the doctrine that you can reduce all
of reality to a data set to
a simple source code and that that does
also have complexity that's non data set
or e so what I'm saying is that there
there are incredible capacities of human
beings in relationship to trans human
powers that did not depend and do not
depend on encompassing more and more of
the world into a data set that is a
certain strategy for engaging reality
I'm not saying it's useless or bad no
what I'm saying is that it is it is
limited to achieve what the Dogon and
other ancient cultures worth of course
we're able to achieve sacred s through
super intelligence that requires a lot
of effort but to limit super
intelligence to a data set I think also
is myopic in a sense there's more to it
we're we're crickets trying to imagine
the big game yeah yeah I don't know
that's I'm just sharing my view about it
I like this and then how about the last
question that we like asking our guests
what do you think's the most beautiful
thing in creation the most beautiful
thing
it depends on the moment that you ask me
how about now
[Music]
well I'm looking at you I'll just feel a
thing don't take the wrong way but
thinking about you - yeah yeah yeah that
shows presence I think mm-hmm I must
also ask you what has been your deepest
experiential connection to creation I'd
say witnessing the birth of my children
that totally took me apart and the
pieces didn't get put together the same
way have you have to have that
experience yeah yeah but hearing from
moms and from other people like yourself
it's like yeah dad's just yeah that
totally changes him Wow and I also want
to make sure that we touch on this
big-picture synthesis as well you
mentioned it and I think it's really
beautiful creation purpose to create
life more aliveness mm-hmm the tendency
of the universe is to become more and
more alive and our purpose in it is to
participate in the coming alive of the
universe yeah that's the that's the
basic my basic understanding to
participate in the coming aliveness of
the universe Charles thank you so much
for coming on the show yeah thank you
for having me on thank you thank you
thank you thanks everyone for tuning in
we greatly appreciate it we'd love to
hear your thoughts in the comments below
on this episode let us know what you're
thinking also have more conversations
that your friends families co-workers
people online about the conversations
that we had on the show about these
topics have more conversations about it
and spread the word more or
the world check out the links in the bio
below as well
you've Charles Eisenstein org you have
all this book links you have his Twitter
profile check those out check out his
books check out his website check out
all that content and everyone and also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders in your
organizations in your communities that
you believe in around the world support
them and help them grow you can find all
of our links below to our show you can
help us grow join us across any of those
platforms below and also go and build
the future everyone manifest your dreams
into the world experience those non-dual
states of awareness we love you very
much thanks for tuning in everyone and
we will see you soon
[Music]
you
[Music]